Okay
Hodor
Okay, I'm done
How are you doing you guys?
hahaha
Wow, I never thought. I would be here. I am so pleased to be here. This is going to be a panel slightly different
I'm going to do things quite informally, we're all friends here aren't we I?
Want to picture yourself you're watching game of thrones on your sofa
Close your eyes think
About all the questions you want to ask us - got yourself in that really relaxed place
Ready to put your hand on your heart got your eyes closed put your hand on your wallet
Bring it up to me
I'll look after it. No. Don't do that. Okay?
These are all my friends guys
These are the people I've worked for six years with on what I think is the best show that's ever been created
And the first guest. I'm sad to say has been a monkey on my back
Six years yes like you what the hell's going on here. There that's better
Ladies and  gentlemen my very good friend and little brother Isaac Hampstead, right
ladies and gentlemen, John Bradley
The amazing Nathalie Emmanuel
Liam Cunningham
It's crazy introducing these guys I've known them since they were like eight years old  so scary Sophie Turner
Ladies and gentlemen Jacob Anderson
My Fellow Countryman, Conleth Hill
Alfie Allen
Ladies and gentlemen - Gwendoline Christie
Hello guys. You all look ravishing absolutely ravishing tonight
So I'm gonna start the questions shall we start the questions? let's start the questions Gwen I'm gonna start with you hello, hi, hi mommy
Okay, we have seen the scene where Tormund makes a play for Brienne
Yeah, I actually have a theory that I think Breanna and Hodor would make a really good couple
I've always held a candle to that.
Very small one
Very small okay, We've seen Tormund make a play for Brienne who seems to be rebuffing his advances
Do you think she secretly enjoys being appreciated as a woman and a warrior?
good question
Well, I think it's really what I love about Brienne of Tarth is that I don't think
that at the foremost of her
Consciousness is a value system. That's based on
how men
appreciate her
but I
Mean who doesn't like being appreciated as both?
Really, but I don't I don't think that's really what she's invested in at all. I think she's finding it incredibly awkward
But underneath any awkwardness is always that
potential
secret enjoyment
What do you all think does she like it?
Or did she like someone else?
What are you saying?
Okay, wow oh Jamie. What - Alfie?
Firstly, what'd he call your dog? What's the name of the dog her name is Abby. That was the cutest thing
I've ever seen in my life
seriously
I really want it
What was it like for you to return to the character of Theon after such a torturous run as reek ?
I'd say it was it was definitely a challenge um I'd say that he wasn't really kind of stepping into the
Feeling that he was before he was turned into reek
But yeah, he's just he's had to definitely a crazy arc of many of the characters on the show
He's been one of the the craziest, but it's um
It's just been enjoyable you know to be able to find empathy for a character such as him. amazing. Thank you Alfie
Conleth
We've never actually had an opportunity to act together. Which is terrible
Many of your fellow cast cite how difficult it can be to keep from laughing while filming with you
Do you purposefully make them laugh?
No.
And is there an actor who makes you laugh?
They all make me laugh
and sometimes
They know it
But mostly they don't but Dinklage would make me laugh a lot yeah. Yeah
Yeah, there's some pretty funny people in the cast that's for sure not you
Jacob
Hello, hi
That's not how I speak y'know- hello
Hello
Is it true?
That we've seen Grey Worm being a bit flirtatious with Missandei and do you see a future for them?
Yeah, I mean, I think there's already this thing's firing between them
This is this chemistry right, I think um
Yeah, I
Want those kids to be happy I want them to find happiness with each other everything so sad
It's never going to happen nothing's ever going to be happy you know
Do you think Daenerys would approve of that relationship? Yeah? I think she's like. She'd do the wedding
She'd like which don't call a wedding. Do you it's not bingo
Yeah, I think she'd be involved yeah
awesome
Not involved. Oh, okay
That's a completely different show. I think you would all watch it, though wouldn't it totally?
Sophie. Hi. Hello, Hello
Is Sa - shut up -
Is Sansa being manipulated by littlefinger, or is she playing the long game?
ah..Good question um yeah, I think
initially you know there was definite manipulation on littlefinger's part, but you know as Sansa has grown and
Been you know a prisoner by all of these master manipulators especially littlefinger
she's been silently absorbing and learning and adapting and
In my opinion, she's just as good at playing the game as he is at this point
Thanks guys.
I love it
Liam
Hello
Look at this a rose between two thorns ah don't say that go ahead answer question
at the end of last season Davos find out about
Mes -I can't really read it -. I really need to wear my glasses Melisandre's part in Sharon's death
Jon Snow banished her from the north and Davos said he would kill her if she ever returned do you think he would and
Does he have it in him to murder someone in cold blood I think that's a good question
I don't I don't think he's the vindictive type. I think
if he was on the road
Taking a long weekend somewhere and in the opposite direction
He saw a lady in a red cape approaching. I think there's a good chance. He'd whip out a glock and
pop a couple of caps in her ass
Hahaha, but I don't think he'd hunt her down
I don't think he'd do an Arya. I don't think he's got a list, but there
But I definitely think he'd put her in a shallow grave somewhere if no one was gonna find out
Now that's just me. Can you just quickly show us how you'd hold a glock yeah, I hold a sideways my leg in the hole
oo Yeah.
I love it
Natalie hi hello
there was a great scene with Tyrion and Grey Worm last season when Tyrion was
Exhorting you both to drink
yeah, Missandei got a little tipsy.
We saw them. We
Saw then that Missandei and Grey Worm were going growing closer
How do you hope that storyline pans out ?
I feel quite similarly to Jacob. I'm like I want these guys to be happy and you know
just stay together I think they've come through so much atrocity so to see them laugh together and
like feels
something for another person is
So beautiful, and I've really enjoyed
portraying that journey, and I hope we get to see it blossom more and maybe there might be a
Happy ending for them. I don't say it just in case
Kiss of death. I know how it feels. I know how
John hello hello
Sam has always considered himself a bit of an outsider. Ya, have Gilly and baby Sam given him a sense of  belonging?
Didn't write these by the way
He's easy absolutely always been an outsider. He was an outsider
from the day
he was born at home because his father considered in to be such a disappointment and
Treated him with such contempt then he was removed to castle black where he was an outsider again
And then he said well the one place I can be really accepted is the citadel
That's the one place. I can go where
My passions and interests aren't treated with scorn
and contempt they're the place where is the place where people have an understanding and appreciation of knowledge and
And this is going to be the place where I feel accepted for the first time in my life
he gets there - he's just as much as an outside of there as he is anywhere else
because they make him do all those jobs that you saw him doing and and
It's interesting that people say how is him being at the citadel going to affect his relationship with Gilly?
Given the fact that they've grown so close over the years
but that was when Sam didn't have thousands and thousands of books as a distraction from his relationship, so I think that as
Time has gone on Sam has worked out a lot of people work out in relationships that you're your kind of sphere of interest
shrinks and you no longer want to be necessarily accepted by a wider world or even a wider community because
you know what's important and important is being loved by two people rather than accepted by
hundreds yeah
Good answer good answer man
This is a very important question. Do you miss me?
No, Of course I do
Know it's been so empty without you on set.
such a liar, okay?
Seriously  he's making me say this
help me
No, okay, this actually is a question which you know as a fan of the show
And I've been there for six years what the hell's name is that Three Eyed Raven about?
The three-eyed Raven what the hell is that about?
Well, I want an in-depth
Analysis like a Wikipedia page. Well what's interesting about the three-eyed Raven is he's one of the sort of
few
fragments that remain of the old Westeros of the the ancient kind of
magical mystical side of it, so
what exactly his purpose is I don't think has has been revealed yet, but
Clearly it's something important. There's been the night King is
Appears to be his sworn enemy, so he must have some important role to play so for Bran this season
Especially it's quite exciting that he is now
It's three eyed Raven, and you don't know them. Yeah. Yeah, that's my rambling wave the same. Yeah, okay, okay?
It's very very informative. Thank you
Right this is for everybody, and I'm going to start right back down at the end with Gwendolyn
I like this question if you ended up on the iron throne, what would be the first law you would pass
Oh no
What would be the first law I would pass The women could be nice
You're gonna change
Same question for you Alfie.
um I
would say that the um
Brotherhood that Beric Dondarrion is part of we be made allowed throughout the land so everyone can come back to life
That works for me
Conleth
and that comic-Con's are free
nice
Jacob
free puppies for everyone
That one. Oh and also some sort of device well where we can create unicorns to exist ?
Mean I don't know how that would work, but everybody needs unicorn you do that. We all need unicorns. Yeah.
Sophie
Because this is really tough the first thing that comes to mind is just like unlimited
Carbohydrates
Don't know why but that's what I want
fair enough
I think in selected outlets all over westeros there should be free dornish wine for all the inhabitants of westeros
You're welcome.
I think Missandei would probably want and I would quite like you know language lessons for everyone they can all be bilingual and cool
Yeah
Education for everyone that's a really serious answer, but also true. How I feel
How about maesters have to clean out their own stinking bedpans?
number one
I've set up a holiday scheme for all the characters
Who have only filmed in the cold places to go and film in the warm places?
I second that yes, second that
Okay, moving back to the individual questions. What about me? Yeah, okay?
I would make it illegal for one person to mount another and be carried
I'm glad you finished that sentence
And every time you have to say thank you. Which you never did
It's not true- that's not true. Yeah that is oh yeah
anyway
Gwendolyn you're always my first
your last your everything
hahahaha
Okay, what do you think it drives Brienne, never give up on her quest to protect the Starks?
I think that the relationship between
Brienne and Catelyn Stark was a moment where Brienne
Realised strength in another woman. I remember quite fervently that line you have it to Catelyn Stark you have strength ah
Not a man's strength but a woman's strength, and I think it was that
realization that
Brienne didn't have to force herself into a mold of masculinity
She didn't have to take the path of men before her in order to be taken seriously or to do good
That she could be propelled by her own
Intuitive sense of of what was right in terms of Moral compass
And I think that there's something very beautiful about the way she's projected that into the future that it doesn't matter of someone's
lives or dies
That that goes into that person's daughters
And it is significant that they are her daughters to return the Stark girls home and in her own way
I think that Brienne feels
That even if it's one small thing for one person or two people that that's going to perpetuate a sense of good
which may be subconsciously creates a greater sense of equality and
that's what I think is driving her it she's connecting to an
Idea that's greater than herself
Wow
and this is why
This is why there isn't just one if you've ever seen me at one of these my answers for basically every question is always Brienne
of Tarth
Yeah, you would be the queen I would put on the throne so
That's why that's why so
Okay, awkward. Alfie-
I love you. Love you, too
Alfie as a true Ironborn
How comfortable is Theon with the fact that he has forsaken his way of life to be on Team Daenerys?
Um,  I think
that the - that Yara is really kind of deciding the the
Journey they take now do their new leadership with Daenerys, so I'd say it's definitely an equal partnership between the two of them
But I would say he's just excited to see where this new leadership takes them, being needed by Daenerys and Yara
Cool
Conleth, how dare you?
Varys is rarely rattled
What do you think scares him?
Oh?
I think the economic outlook
And I, well, something whatever that Sorcerer said
We you know we saw him with a red priestess. We were it was one of the two times where he looked a bit whaaat
Because she was cray
but
yeah, I think that's that's you know he
survived so much, but that's the one thing we don't know what was said and and because of your
Experience with you know words and hold the door and everything I think "oh God. I'm gonna be holding a door for someone"
And that's what the sorcerer said, so that's the only thing I'm kind of
You know there's a mystery there that I still don't know what that's about
What was said and what it means well my advice when it comes to holding doors is don't
all right
Or get a swinging door. Yeah, I'm thinking it never ends well
Jacob
Yeah, yeah
Some of you some of you out there may know Jacob is also a very talented musician
wooo!
Thank you. How do you balance both sides of your career?
um
I kind of don't I have I'm really lucky um
I've got like we the way we shoot the show is kind of
Over a period I don't know why I'm telling you this
The way we shoot the show is like
It's like six months, and then we're all kind of in and out kind of revolving doors. Sorry it was a
Trigger um
and um so I just whenever I'm
Not in Belfast or or a sunny place
Just rub it in, man rub it in you talk about doors. You're talking about the sunshine
right songs um yeah, it's not been too bad actually it's not been hard
I mean could - my life could be worse.
Mean I'm really nervous by the way. This is like. I'm at home here, but for some reason I've already lost it
Why don't you give us a rendition of your song?
What song do you want to hear?
Well, not one of my songs, you really don't want to hear my songs
I thought it might calm your nerves
ah, okay. Calm your nerves....
Calm your nerves...beautiful
is that you shutting me up?
Yeah
it was about to get really really exciting. I was about to go into like
A medley yeah Medley I
Just thought that was just a Edelweiss   wasn't it yeah this
Thank you, Jacob.
I mean yeah, I know what it's about. I know what it's about, balancing two careers
I was I was like actually DJing up like 2 am.  I don't bounce I just I just do it
Yeah, we do you ever he just do it. Yeah
Sophie hi, hi
Does Sansa retain any of her ideas about love marriage and being happy or
Is she now the opinion that men are just after her for what she can get what they can get?
ahh..I don't think I
Don't think she's like season one Sansa and she's particularly looking for it's not really looking for a relationship
Or love at the moment. I think she's kind of done with that
I think you know she's always on the search for happiness, but she doesn't really see the world through rose-tinted glasses anymore, you know
She sees the reality of the situation in terms of like seeing men
In a different light I think she sees the world in a different light I don't think men in particular. I think she
you've broken that man's heart.
Um I mean of course she's you know she's just kind of she's woke now guys. She's real woke
You know she's cautious. She trusts no one
Whether it be man or woman and whether a family member or not she trusts no one and I think that's important
when you play the game of thrones
Liam.
Yes
Do you think Davos misses his smuggling days?
When life was simpler and he is able to live by his wits
yeah, that's a kind of an interesting question because
Him being promoted from small-time criminal to being sucked into this web this game
There's very little room. I think it reflects real life when people
End up in powerful positions it - you can't have a simple life anymore
It's very difficult to be just happy you're playing games, you're paranoid
Who's out to get you or the whole thing but I think he felt he had a responsibility to be there to try and heed
whoever it may be on the right track and
Because he's decent and he's loyal and he doesn't
He doesn't have that addiction for this horrible drug that is power
So is his head is kind of his head. It's a little bit clearer than some
But I do I do like the guy's I
Love the guy's simplicity it's he is who he is and he's he's not a complicated character
And it's really nice for dinner. It's really nice to play somebody like that and play those little colorism
I really I really love this character.
I think that's one of the special things about George R Martin's writing- that every single character, no matter how small they are, is completely multi-layered. We all get such a--that's a gift
What do you mean small?
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I don't mean you. I only had one word. I don't think I can compete hello
Anyway, Nathalie
We know that Missandei owes a debt to Daenerys as she freed her from slavery
Do you think Daenerys should have made Missandei her hand instead of Tyrion ?
That's a great question um. I don't know about that. That would be cool
I'd love to
play that but I think you know Tyrion knows the enemy he is
much more experienced with being a hand he and that sort of political landscape
I think Missandei has come from a completely different world
she's been dealing with a completely different set of dangers, but like she you know this sort of strategizing and
negotiating this
Very cutthroat world all of a sudden is is
So new so I think Tyrion is probably the better candidate for hand and I fully support him in that role
Although it would be super cool to be like hand to like your bestie. You know
like girl power
you know
Double-team like it'd be pretty fun
I think he would admit an awesome hand actually I will thank you to be a thank you. I appreciate
John Mm-Hmm, when Samwell was a member of the nights watch. Yeah, Jon Snow was his constant protector
Yeah, how much of an influence he think Jon still has over him and how much the Samwell want to please Jon?
Sam no that's alright -Sam arrived at castle black
completely bereft of any positive
Male role model in his life and indeed the positive female role model that he had had been very cruelly taken away from him
So what he found in Jon snow in that moment was everything
He possibly needed all kind of wrapped up in one person. He was it was a big brother. He was a father figure
He was a confidant. He was the best friend. It was all of those things and
Sam knew what it was like to be saved by somebody
Knew what it was like to be saved by Jon Snow and knew what it was like
to have somebody take the burden of you on their shoulders and
when he found Gilly he found somebody in even more kind of emotional dire straits than he was who had a life of
systematic sexual abuse
laid out in front of her and the worst possible life you can imagine so he knew what it was like to be saved at
That point so he wanted to do that for somebody else
He wanted he wanted to save this girl and her son because he knows how important that can be it was like
Jon handed a baton on to Sam and
and..and..
Jon Snow was kind of everything to Sam and now
they-they've gone on their separate paths because
Sam wants to please him so much because he wants to fight the same battle as Jon Snow
He wants to stand shoulder to shoulder with Jon Snow in the great war
But he knows that he can't do that on the battlefield
He knows that he has to do that using his very unique set of skills which is
Academia and learning and applying knowledge
You know if the citadel his battlefield and so John sent him there and now he has - he has the responsibility to
Make Jon's faith and him justified and get Jon results
He knows it's a race against time
He needs to get in there find out whatever piece of information
He needs to find out get back up to the north and give it to Jon Snow that that's what he any feels about
responsibility all the time he he knows he's got a huge debt to repay to John and he feels that very strongly and
Fingers crossed he does just that, right?
right Isaac in certain spiritual traditions
the Third eye refers to the gift that leads to inner realms and
spaces of higher consciousness
do you think that applies to the three-eyed Raven or is it all about the Raven
yeah, I think in many ways it does because
I've always said that if I could have any superpower it would be to be all-knowing and that's exactly what Bran is now
He's learned
With the original three-eyed Raven and now he has access to like this vast encyclopedia
of all of history
And not only can he just read someone's perspective of it
He can actually exist there in that time and watch it happen, so if that's not one of the deepest and most
Interesting realms there is then I'm not sure what what is
this is obviously very important those questions
Gwendoline
if there were one character hodor
That you wished hadn't been killed hodor
who would it be? hodor
Well, I mean there's two people obviously
one is
someone who was a
magnificent presence in the series who happens to be hosting this panel?
and also Catelyn Stark
big answer real answer
Alfie
Who would I like to be brought back to life? Yeah pretty much?
um, I would say
Karl Drago, I like Karl Drogo. Karl Drogo. Definitely, Karl Drogo
Conleth?
Um..Catelyn and......you
oh, you have to say that
I'm - I'm still hurting about Ned
Still breaks my heart.
It takes a while to get over that one.
I also have a flame for Barristan Selmy. Hold one up for Barristan
I just really loved working with Jack Gleeson so much that I have to say Joffrey
Wow,
He was such a good husband. Haha.
Very generous man
Yeah, I i have no choice. I have to say my baby girl Shireen
That still hurts. Big time.
Think I
Am still
Heartbroken about Hodor like I still I honestly just
Can't quite fit into words, but I you know I just love you what your guys like whole thing
So I think my answer is Hodor
Okay, like so many
yea, two answers again first and foremost become the legitimate answer is Robb Stark
And the second answer is if there's one character that I wish they hadn't killed
It'd be Jon Snow just to say he was having to talk about every five minutes for a year
That whole year was pretty bad that was a pretty crummy year
Yeah, you know I have to go out in the newspapers if I thought someone asked me for like 37th time the hour is Jon
Snow coming back, and I just lost it. I was like you know what? I don't care yeah
and um, next day in the paper. It said Kristian Nairn hates Kit Harington
I didn't say that
Isaac yeah you've been very careful
Shae!
yea, actually some of the direwolves. I'd bring back Hodor.
Did you even like the direwolves?
Stop you
have no legs actually so you
After so much time working on game of thrones
Are you ready to act in a comedy rom-Com or a musical or would you like to act or direct? or?
I feel like game thrones incorporates
Rom-Com musical you know
Uh, I don't know I like the dark
gritty stuff
But I uh I don't know if I could do comedy after all this I'm in a very dark place in my life
Yeah, I can second that - she is
Let's see Alfie. Yes
Would you like to be in a rom-com, or would you like to act or direct?
I know you love nothing more than to be in a role nothing more
Yeah, no, I mean yeah to just any anything that comes my way
You know even um you know I'll just I'll just you know
Take anything on but yeah directing is something that would definitely interest me about a job
Cool man
Gwen
I'm desperate to do a musical
Please someone put me in a musical. Yeah kind of Marlene Dietrich kind of
gender-bending Sort of song and dance
cabaret type thing maybe
If I ask this question I'll prerequisite, I won't to ask you to prove it, but can you sing?
Don't know this. I don't know the answer to that
the Jury's out on that
small aspect of doing a musical
But I hear they can do all sorts of technology these days
It's called miming
okay,
Isaac
I'd like to be in Game of Thrones the comedy rom-Com musical
Wow, I hope that goes
well
It would just be a comedy rom-Com musical and what more might work might behind the door and like tap dance
Yeah, I mean, you could have all sorts of different musical numbers. It's it's ripe for a musical adaptation
Shall we do it. Yeah?
David and Dan? we're just the people to do it you play the piano. I enjoy the guitar
They're sending me a whole band here actually
John Um
when I was 13 years old I
played Potiphar,  the plum Role of Potiphar in
joseph and his amazing technicolor dreamcoat at school.
wow
Couldn't sing then can't sing now
Absolutely stormed it somehow there. Nice. If so, it'd be interesting to see how standards of risen over time
I'd be interested in reprising my iconic role as Potiphar on the London stage for a hefty old fee
Liam
I'd love to do some comedy. I did I did a lot of comedy on stage before I started this television business
But I met Peter Dinklage Peter Dinklage was asked. What did he think?
How'd the think the last episode should go, and
He thinks the last episode of the entire show should be a musical yeah, I think it's a brilliant idea
Well, we're breaking the norms with television. Let's go that way
Let's finish with a high kicking number around it around the throne why not
I'd watch it. Yeah
there's as a danger of doing it this way I've forgotten who I asked - Conleth
I am I'm happy to take a rest and let other people do rom coms comedies
And what was the other one it was oh, no, they're not getting to me. Oh, so
Now I've done it all good night
Wow
Jacob yeah, I want to I want to make films, but um
that wasn't, that wasn't an option, rom-com, comedy-
I'll read that again for you-? I'm like super Greedy. I wouldn't you everything um
Yeah, I it's quite. This is quite a hard show to
Follow I would you two like Master Spearsmen now
This is hard, and I'd so I just want to do like hard things
So I guess like a comedy or a rom-Com would be quite hard
I do want to you know because there's this talk of spin-offs of the show
I just want to put my hat in the ring now and just say I
Really like the idea
I've been talking to Daniel Portman he plays Pod and we've been talking about a sort of side call to the show
Where grey worm and Pod and maybe Daario Naharis ?
Cyborg? Side call . It's like ah so when you not see I've already horn
But will you get like cameos like Bran would come in and be like --as a Cyborg?
Don't thought oh sure. Yeah, wow babe. Let's go with the cyborgs version. I want the cyborg version
the Borg Invade Westeros
Could we do that please?
Actually I can announce that the HBO spin-off has already been decided it's going to be called Better Call Davos
You're welcome
And good night
Nathalie
Yeah, I am. I'm sort of open to all things. I don't actually absolutist for anything like I don't want to do this
I don't want to do that because you never know what comes
Into your you know
Email inbox you know you're like. Oh, that's a good script, or that's be a fun thing to do actually started off doing musicals and
So I am so open to doing a musical whether I can sing as well as I should
I mean, you know, but I'd give it a go and
You know other stuff like I'd love to I've already still
Attempting to write things and I'd love to be behind the camera too say I'm so it was just like going with the flow
Awesome. I think we've had some really good ideas for a borg musical and westeros. I'm going to start working in that right away
And now we're going to open up the floor to you guys. Which is the most important part of the panel
which crowd is
crazier
the game of Thrones crowd or
Star wars yeah
because
people always ask me this and
I can't really I mean I should have come up with a better answer by now really there's absolutely no excuse
I don't think it's - a I mean. It's not really a craziness, but the level of passion is
pretty much equal and
I'm hugely lucky to be involved with both projects to be involved with the project
What is noticeable is Star wars is something that many of us have grown up with that gives us actually?
What I feel is a sense of home
About star wars, that's how I feel I feel like I've come home and it's amazing the way game of thrones is
7 we're going into the seventh season now
But there's a similar feeling actually which I think is much of the passion and love and I look forward to
The resonance of game of thrones carrying on through people's lives, so they still have they have that same feeling of
Home and love for it
Hello, my name's Lila from San Diego
And I just want to say your show is the best show on television right now is you're amazing. I love it. Thank you and
My question is for Sophie um
How is your relationship with your?
with Jon now that you've reunited and
also
Since you're running low on brothers lately
I have a proposition for you
Can I be a Stark?
Yeah, you can - you're a Stark
Yeah, we have a new Stark. Easy as that see it was a easy to replace brothers ah
Third question whoa. Oh right um Jon and Sansa
I've forgotten the question what were together again right together again. How does it feel losing - oh, that's right um
It's it's you know. There's still that kind of sibling rivalry from back when they were very young and they reunited and
There's still kind of those
those kind of
That sexism. That's just ingrained in the culture
Where the men are the the fighting figures and the women just kind of say nothing when really Sansa is
Politically especially to do with battle of the bastards was very
She was very knowledgeable about how to deal with the situation deal with the Bolton's and so it's about them finding that balance
and
Finding that collaboration, but it's it's proving quite difficult. He's the military man
She's a politician
But I think they both need to realize that they need to stop fighting for ultimate power and just work together
This is for
Gwendolyn now
Tormund
seems to have only one move with the ladies. Which is like the same move I have which is a
creepy smile
so
what else
Would Tormund -- what else could he do?
to get in
Brienne's chain mail?   Wash
Well, let's not forget Tormund does certainly have his very well-put creepy smile
He also enjoys
masticating food at Brienne as we saw him really going down on that chicken Leg ah
Yeah, it didn't do much for her. Did it um I?
Think really it's about
Really in order to win Brienne's heart. It's about a mutual respect
that isn't about any sort of
Overpowering or sexual advance it has to be about a mutual
Respect that's born out of skill and uh and a nobility about your ideals
And you think that's gonna happen with Tormund?
Haha, well it so doesn't happen it  with you
You know you might get lucky
There are kids here -- there are kids here
So tell me -- It speaks!
dragons
Direwolves and three-eyed Ravens cannot save you
So are you looking forward to rising again as the children of a cold?
mic drop
I've been here nobody knows what you said dude
This definite art refers the first time we've heard the night king speech
are you looking forward to rising again as the children of the cold
Great question, we don't have much choice in the matter do we ha ha ha ha absolutely not
I didn't realize the night King is Californian
Hey, I'm from Philadelphia y'all
It's the make-up made you sound like you were from the valley
I'm only out here because of the Marine Corps
That's why the night Kings formidable. He was in the Marine Corps
Thank you, dude. You look incredible. Yeah, you do man, beautiful costume